[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory I've
noticed that quite a few of you have
asked for a video on one less magic now
we know that in the Wizarding World it
is commonplace for young witches and
wizards
to visit Ollivanders and receive their
first want with their wand they could
begin to practice magic and hone their
magical abilities ones help them to
channel their magic and achieve a more
accurate or potent result generally in
order to cast a spell it is required of
the caster to utter the correct words
and wave the wand accordingly how the
words are said how the wonders moved can
depend on the spell if you want to hear
my theory on how these patterns are
determined and how spells are created
check out the link in the description
after you've finished here anyway moving
along if magic is conjured fear the wand
then what reasonable explanation could
there be for one to less magic we see
wondrous magic from the likes of
Dumbledore Voldemort moody Flitwick and
many more
how and why do they do it what's
interesting about Wonders magic is that
it really only stands out to us because
of its ubiquity among the Wizarding
World that we have become familiarized
with through the books and films
we are indoctrinated from the start to
think that a wand is essential to
magical achievement when in reality one
this magic is actually a norm for other
species in cultures prime examples of
magical beings that perform magic
without once include goblins and elves
who are even known to refer to humans as
wand bearers expanding on this in the
world of Harry Potter
the wand is said to be a European
invention which means that cultures
outside of Europe would have always
practiced magic without one it is said
that Native American Wizards have their
own methods of producing magic predating
colonisation and that African Wizards
only adopted the wand in the 20th
century so really oneness magic is a lot
more common than you may think outside
of these cultures and species I feel
that the use of one was magic in a world
whether we use of a1 is ubiquitous can
be attributed to one of two things a
powerful magical ability vast experience
in calculated casting or B lack of
experience in accidental casting
underaged witches and wizards who have
yet to receive their first wand have
been known to cast this type of magic
most often the reason for this is that
the children had a lack of control over
their abilities thus unintentionally
casting a spell experienced witches in
Wizards however most likely cast
wondrous magic out of convenience
Wizards like Dumbledore or Voldemort are
so powerful and versed in magic they
really see no use for wand in most
everyday circumstances the magic has
been fine-tuned to the point that it
would not make sense for them to pull
out a one-two every five minutes however
it is said that if one this magic is
performed incorrectly it can produce
unfavorable results which would deter a
lot of the general population who are
not accustomed to it
however for powerful wizards this
wouldn't even be a consideration because
they are so confident in their magical
capabilities one question that should be
answered here is if one form of
producing magic is more powerful than
the other one versus no wand the answer
to this question is of course that magic
produced with a wand is more powerful I
can say this with confidence because if
producing one this magic was as or more
powerful than magic with a wand then
powerful wizards would be doing it under
all circumstances in reality in more
important situations where more power is
required we see Voldemort and Dumbledore
using ones
a prime example of this is their jewel
in the ministry atrium where they would
have really needed to hone in on their
magical capabilities expanding on that
it is said to be a pain point in the
relationship between elves goblins and
humans the humans will not disclose the
secrets producing magic with a wand this
suggests to me that the use of a wand
must be better somehow additionally if
African countries practiced magic
without a one for so long and only later
adopted it then there must be some
appeal or rationale
one usage with all of that said I think
that we conclude a few things the first
thing that oneness magic is more
convenient
the second that oneness magic is riskier
and more complicated and the third being
that one is magic produced by the same
wizard is not as powerful as magic that
comes from a wand that's all for this
video if you enjoyed it please give the
video a like as always if you have any
questions or video ideas then comment
them down below until next time you're a
wizard Harry
[Music]